[Music]
all these people working together to
help me
mr serial killer
make that mr serial killer and son
[Music]
hey guys pete here today i'm talking
about the ending of dexter new blood
episode 10 brought the limited series to
a conclusion and provided an unambiguous
ending for the character dexter morgan
i'll be recapping the main points of
what happened in the finale which was
titled sins of the father and then talk
about what the ending was trying to
convey we'll be getting into all of that
right after a quick spoiler warning if
you haven't watched episode 10 of dexter
new blood then this video won't be for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it dexter morgan is dead
there's not even really any wiggle room
there they decided to kill him off and
it's done in order to understand how we
got there we do have to look back at the
original series finale the 12th and
final episode of its eighth season at
the end of that dexter had abandoned his
son harrison thinking he was better off
with his girlfriend hannah who was also
a killer they traveled to argentina to
start a new life knowing that she would
never recover he unplugged his sister
deb's life support after she slipped
into a coma he dropped her body into the
ocean and then drove his boat into
hurricane lora and new blood clarified
that he was trying to end his life here
laura is a reference to his biological
mother's name and of course witnessing
her death as a child was the
foundational event that defined most of
dexter's life after he survived the
hurricane he explained in a letter that
he sent to hannah that the experience
showed him that he had to bear the
burden of his urges alone in his mind he
would leave everyone behind live in a
self-imposed exile where he wouldn't be
in a position to endanger anyone but
himself after the loss of deb he
realized that everyone he cares about
that stays close to him suffers because
of what he does they all eventually die
and we will come back around to this
letter at the end and discuss how it
informs his decisions at the very end of
his life the season 8 finale ended with
dexter alone working as a lumberjack
somewhere in oregon at the beginning of
new blood we learned that his
self-imposed exile included remaining
abstinent from indulging his dark
passenger he gone almost 10 years
without killing anyone and managed to
put together about as normal of a life
as he could hope for living under the
assumed name jim lindsey and working at
the local fish and game store while he
still goes to great lengths to try to
look normal and blend in he did decide
to enter into a relationship with the
local chief of police the implication is
that he wanted to stay close to the
action more than he wanted to completely
limit the chances that his real identity
might be exposed it's a classic
situation where dexter wants to control
everything around him and this time it
does come back to bite him in the end
things start to get disrupted in this
newfound normal life he's built on
routine when two sons arrive in iron
lake matt caudwell the son of a
successful local businessman he'll
become dexter's first kill in a long
time in a situation where he bends the
code almost to absurdity because this
guy really rubs him the wrong way and
his son harrison also arrives who is
fresh off of an awful experience with
the foster care system after losing his
adoptive mom hannah who dexter left him
with to cancer initially dexter tries to
turn harrison away telling him he's made
a mistake that he's jim lindsey and he's
not his father but after he kills matt
he decides to tell him the truth he
welcomes his son into his life and they
struggle to connect until he realizes
that harrison struggles with violent
urges related to his past he focuses in
on the fact that they both witness their
mothers being murdered and decides that
he'll come clean and tell him everything
he tells him that he has similar urges
and that his adoptive father harry
taught him a way to control them by
using a code to kill people who the
justice system has failed to catch
being a vigilante sounds good to
harrison at first and they do kill kirk
caldwell together in the penultimate
episode and in the lead-up to the finale
dexter thinks he's finally found what he
always wanted someone who knows what he
is and what he does and can accept him
at the same time his girlfriend angela
who'd grown suspicious after learning
about him faking his death started to
put together the pieces to connect him
to the bay harbor butcher killings from
his past this was helped along by kurt
sending her surgical screws as evidence
that he killed his son matt and in the
beginning of the final episode she
discovers another one of the set in the
ruins of dexter's burnt down cabin that
will lead to his arrest but before she's
able to do that we get our first glimpse
of how the curt kill has changed
dexter's mindset he's looking around and
notices how many nice and helpful people
live in iron lake and realizes that
they'll have to leave in order to have
more victims harrison is reluctant
because he finally feels like he fits in
somewhere but dex explains they'll need
to satisfy their urges to keep the dark
passengers at bay it's in this moment
that you realize that this is more about
his desires than what's best for his son
angela takes him into custody and you
see the moment when she loses any doubt
she might be wrong as he hears the
charges dexter says matt's dead and the
effortlessness of the lie seems to
confirm her suspicions he's booked as
dexter morgan not jim lindsey and when
they sit down for the interview she says
hello dexter morgan which is a nice call
back to the trinity killer she presents
him with the evidence she has which to
his credit isn't very strong and he does
his normal routine of doing a pretty
good job of talking his way out of it he
makes a fairly compelling case sinking
on his feet after hearing her working
theory and using the fact that kurt had
a grudge against her for his arrest it
all ties into him burning down the cabin
so the screw would be found and when he
pivots to try to start talking about the
problems she's having related to
learning about iris he really pushes a
button which prompts logan to come in
and break things up when logan and
angela talk he points out that dexter's
story is plausible enough to sway a jury
and therefore a da will be hesitant to
file charges of course she has a lot
more on her mind because of her
investigation into his connection to the
bay harbor butcher but she still isn't
ready to mention those suspicions and
holds back on this initially because she
feels like she needs to be sure this
time dexter is allowed to meet with
harrison for five minutes and he
explains that he has nothing to worry
about because it's not related to kurt
and assures them that he's been in
tougher spots before and that they'll
get out of it they hug and he tells him
that the world needs us implying that
the world needs this kind of vigilante
justice that only they can deliver and
you can see that this doesn't have the
intended effect on harrison he looks
conflicted about it logan and harrison
have a moment in his room at the tavern
and basically he realizes what a good
guy he is angela decides to call batista
and ask about the bay harbor butcher
case she asked him if he believed that
dokes really did it which he did at the
time but he also brings up that his
ex-wife maria laguerta thought that it
was dexter morgan only he died years ago
she sends him a picture of them together
to show that he's still alive and he
immediately says that he'll be there
first thing tomorrow morning and he'll
be bringing everything he has
with this new information angela returns
to interview dexter again she brings up
the ketamine and then shows him
everything she's got that makes her
believe that he's the bay harbor butcher
there's a point where i think she lets
her emotions get the best of her telling
him that batista was coming there the
next morning it's here where you see him
change his strategy instead of riding it
out and hoping that her weak evidence
won't hold he decides to try to get her
out of the station so he can try to find
a way to escape he tells her to turn off
the camera and when she eventually does
he tells her about kurt's underground
bunker this really serves no purpose for
him except buying a little time and in
that that makes her only appearance
before the very end over the course of
the season we had been seeing less and
less of deb in each episode as dexter
started to embrace his old self and
decided to expose everything to harrison
he stopped allowing that voice of doubt
that comes through deb to influence his
decisions he or she reminds him about
how earlier in the season he started
thinking that not killing might be the
problem and when she doubts his ability
to get around angela he gets angry and
then calls for logan to bring him some
water he uses this as a chance to try to
force him to let him go he smashes his
face against the bars and then he gets
him in a choke hold he gives him the
opportunity to unlock the cell and just
let him go so he can go see harrison but
logan makes the decision to go for his
gun and tries to shoot dexter who then
snaps his neck killing him this is a
point of no return there isn't much he
can do besides take his keys and try to
leave and he calls harrison with logan's
phone and tells him to get his truck and
meet him where they found the white deer
at the same time angela arrives at
kurt's cabin and finds the bunker she
goes inside and discovers all the bodies
in the trophy cases and after putting
everything together and seeing molly
park's body there she comes up to call
for backup she obviously can't reach
logan so she calls teddy and finds out
that he hasn't talked to him in the last
hour she rushes back to the station to
find his body and learns that dexter
escaped when he meets up with harrison
covered with blood in the woods his son
wants to know where it came from he
realizes that it came from logan because
he called him from his phone and dexter
tries to tell him there was no other way
he goes further to try to make it about
him saying it was the only way i could
get back to you and goes as far as
saying that i need to be with you none
of this is really landing because of
what happened to get them to that point
harrison really begins to question if
they're the same after all he was on
board because he thought about it as
saving innocent lives but here he sees
the failings and how innocent people can
get swept up in it too he decides that
he doesn't want to leave town together
he wants it to end and he thinks that
his father needs to turn himself in
dexter explains that he would get the
death penalty which means he won't do
that and his son says maybe that's what
you deserve realizing that he's running
out of time dexter tells harrison that
he doesn't have to come along but that
he can't stay there anymore as he's
walking away harrison pulls out his
rifle and demands to know if his mother
and his aunt deb would still be alive if
it wasn't for dexter and when he says
open your eyes and look at what you've
done saying the same words that dexter
said in the very first kill that we saw
in the first season it finally hits
dexter and he thinks of some of the
innocent people that died as a direct
result of his inability to stop killing
in that moment he decides to make the
ultimate sacrifice for his son he tells
him that he's sorry for everything he's
done that he deserved better a better
life a better father and realizing that
he was about to walk away from the son
that had waited to be together for so
long and had felt abandoned for all
these years he breaks down and he tells
him that he has to take the safety off
just like i showed you and assures him
that this is the only way out and they
both understand this they understand
that they're trapped in this cycle and
this is the only way it can come to an
end he guides him to shoot him in the
heart and just before that happens we
hear in voiceover i've never felt real
love until now meaning this one selfless
choice made for his son felt right and
you hear him say you did good as he
expires with his sister deb holding his
hand as he goes angela shows up and
tells harrison to get out of there she
gives him some cash tells him to take
the truck gives him directions and tells
him never to come back she cleans off
his prints and calls it in to take
responsibility for it herself we see
that he has kurt's cash and when he's
getting ready to leave the scene he sees
the letter that dexter sent to hannah
this reminds the viewers that he had
already come to this conclusion before
harrison re-entered his life as we hear
him read it in voiceover we understand
that he went against his own plan and
welcomed harrison back into his life
because he couldn't bear to send him
away in that moment he hoped that he
could make it work in spite of the fact
that he was already picking up on his
old behaviors when the prospect came up
to be himself and bring harrison along
for the ride he jumped at it and in the
end he was ready to abandon him again if
he wasn't willing to accept that future
it's a tragic end that fits for the
character and the letter reinforces that
he always knew that harrison would be
better off without him he did what he
thought he had to do to give him a
chance and he accepted that it was his
sacrifice to make it's not the kind of
end that will satisfy everyone who
wanted the story to continue but it's
the one that they set up and delivered
let me die so my son can live he went
out on his own terms and i think that's
a good place to leave things let me know
what you think about it in the comments
it's certainly divisive i knew a lot of
people were going to be disappointed and
not like the finale if he died based on
the feedback to my last couple of videos
where i said that i thought that was the
most likely outcome and it wasn't a
perfect season or finale it had its
issues i think that's pretty standard
for dexter and i think everyone has
their own limits on what they're willing
to overlook and if they would have got
the ending they wanted they would have
been happy to overlook those things i
think they rejuvenated the character
they brought back the excitement and the
tension from the early seasons and i
think we saw some of michael c hall's
best acting from the entire series so
i'm not mad i decided to watch it dexter
dying was inevitable and it looks like
clyde was right it did break the
internet please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon